i'm very pleased that today
uh because of the vaccine rollout uh
we're able to
say to people coming back from uh
anywhere in the eu
plus i think switzerland plus the united
states that they don't have to
to quarantine so double jab people and
no longer have to
to quarantine and what i want to do
is obviously understand people
care very much about their their
holidays people want to go abroad i
understand how much people
plan prepare for the summer holidays
but we've also got to remember that this
is still a dangerous
virus and that we must try and stop
variants coming in must drop importing
variants from abroad so we have to have
a balanced approach and what i want to
see is a
something that is as simple and as user
friendly
for people as possible but obviously the
uh the the double vaccinations that
we've got
really do offer uh the way forward i
think we've now got
more than 70 i think 72 percent of the
populations now
has now had two jabs but what do you say
to critics with your own party in
business that say we're
squandering our vaccine dividend by not
opening up international traffic
the uk is uh has been able to roll out
vaccines at a pace that has you know
been i think pretty good we've now
vaccinated more than
uh people that any other country in in
europe and that means actually that the
uk
economy and society is just about the
most open
uh in europe and you'll have seen the
figures from the imf
about growth in the uk the the bounce
back that you're seeing
in the uk economy that is directly
attributable to that opening up and
to that vaccine right on travel we've
we've had to balance it because of the
anxiety that i think a lot of people
have i have about importing
new variants bringing back the disease
but we also have to recognize that
people want
badly to go on their summer holidays we
need to get people
get the travel industry moving again we
need to get our city centers
open again and so we want an approach
that is as as simple
as as we can possibly make it if i can
just quickly ask on iran
uh your government has said that you
believe iran is responsible for the
attack on the tanker
what sort of response are you
considering is a military response on
the table
i think that iran should
face up to the consequences of what
they've done except that
the attribution that the foreign
secretary has made
this was clearly an unacceptable and
outrageous attack on
commercial shipping a uk national
died it is absolutely vital that iran
and every other country
respects the freedoms of navigation
around the world and
the uk will continue to insist on that